um the cultural revolution they don't
want to talk about
even now um right after mao died they
admitted that he was 30
wrong but 70 right and then they blamed
it on his wife
and the gang of four so they basically
found other scapegoats that they could
use so that they could still use mao as
like the great helmsman
and that gives you an idea of how bad
the cultural revolution was the party
does not admit
any wrongdoing wow and it was so bad
that they were like okay maybe mal was
not
like 100 on the ball with that and but
it was his wife mostly
so i have a i have a friend uh i
mentioned i have a friend in ukraine and
she was telling me how
uh when i was at her apartment it's like
these old soviet communist bloc
buildings
that neighbors who would have disputes
the easy way to resolve a dispute
was they would just call you know the
police and say my neighbor is saying is
bad-mouthing the party
and then the next day the apartment
would be empty and the person would be
gone off to the gulags to go break rocks
i know a story kind of similar uh from
somebody i spoke to who lived this in
china like
uh again top-down government regulations
there mao said there was a specific
number
of percentage of the population in each
area that would be counter
revolutionaries
uh and it would need to be purged so
there would be meetings where
like the local people like the they have
to decide who is the who is the
witch basically and what it was is like
it would they would just wait until like
the first person had to leave to go use
the restroom
and that was that was him it was him my
grandfather actually got
arrested in china not during the
cultural revolution this was
you have to understand that the cultural
revolution was the biggest and worst of
these political campaigns but they never
stopped
like you know organ harvesting of falun
gong yeah since the chinese communist
party went came to power in 1949 in the
50s there was the anti-writers movement
there was the
100 flowers campaign where mao was
basically like
i'm going to let 100 flowers bloom
please come criticize the party so we
know how to do better and then they
basically rounded up uh and imprisoned
and killed all the people who criticized
the party
yeah uh you know so then you had the the
great leap forward the cultural
revolution
there's a test yeah they're in the 80s
yeah they did
in the 80s there were things like um my
my grandfather was arrested during one
called the anti-spiritual pollution
campaign
which was like the too many western
elements are coming into china we need
to like
purge the spiritual things you know what
i would do
i'd be like i i have a criticism the
chinese communist party is too good
it's just too good that wouldn't work
it's too good in the cultural revolution
that's a good criticism there was this
movement where i forget which country
was but somebody gifted
mao mangos it was um pakistan
okay pakistan and mangoes were like
totally unheard of in china at this time
and so then there became this cult of
people worshipping mao's mangos
no i remember this because what happened
was oh i don't remember this my father
remembered this he told me the story
many times like
he remembered yeah he remembered it
because um the
prime minister of pakistan gave mao this
like mangoes
mao gave them to the people like he went
to like a particular
factory and we're like the workers in
this factory should get the mangoes and
the workers at the factory were like
mao gave us these mangoes we cannot eat
them like let them become
like symbols of his like love for the
people you know
so then they literally like paraded the
mangoes around the country
there are propaganda photos where it's
like the mass of people and somebody
holding up a plate of mango
there is literally a propaganda movie
where they're marching down the street
with mangoes
uh it was a huge parade of people and
then like
take a look at this the cult of mangoes
look at this paintings of someone
holding up mangoes and his little
trophies
yeah they would make trophies they made
these like fake
mangoes miraculous mangoes oh that's our
episode
yeah that is yeah yeah so they made
these fake mangoes that they then like
brought around to all the different
places in china and were like
look at look upon mao's mangoes and my
dad went when they came to his village
to like see the mango and he remembered
like everybody was so
excited to see the mango that came from
mao
and then later he realized it was a
plastic mango
because obviously the mangoes wouldn't
have like lasted that long but at the
time everybody
really believed that this was one of the
mangoes like from mao personally
yeah and in in that episode we talk
about a story of where like one guy
who was like oh it looks like a sweet
potato they executed him
oh man well let's be honest if there's
one thing that communists are good at
it's sending people to jail and killing
them so at least they're good at that
they're really good at killing people
yeah they're great 100 million or more
than that yeah well it's interesting we
were talking to somebody about you know
oftentimes people will say oh well
you know they're great technocrats there
in china and and that's actually like a
horrible
thing to to it's what it is is like they
have these soulless
solutions to problems like if you have
too many falun gong people you need some
organs
simple technocratic solution take their
organ sell it
it's become huge business there you go
and then i think the thing with us
admiring the technocratic ability of
china like when you see
in the wall street journal or the new
york times they're talking about like
you know china's technocrats that build
these like huge skyscrapers and these
like
which are not just gdp scans you know or
high-speed rail which they stole from
japan
like all of this kind of stuff and like
we admire that
um in a way and like we're like being
this this way technocratic is good
um and then we don't it's like taking
the morality out of it because if you
don't talk about
you can't say genocide if you talk about
genocide
then you have to kind of grapple with
what is actually happening in china well
maybe we shouldn't be doing business
there
well another aspect that kind of really
worries me with the technocracy is the
development of artificial
intelligence which we know china is
rapidly working on with some of the
biggest corporations in the world
how do you see this kind of race which
vladimir putin has kind of
described as building the next nuclear
weapon which he described artificial
intelligence as
specifically in relation to china well
it's not just it's not just ai there is
this bigger problem of
china the chinese communist party
obviously has no moral regulations on
things
so they're able to invite scientists
from around the world to come to china
and do uh we we spoke to a geneticist
about this
they can do any get this this is getting
into alex jones territory yeah
uh congratulations for not being banned
for having them on twice
um but yeah they can they they offer
scientists and businesses from around
the world just unlimited sums of money
to do whatever
and uh you know because there are no
privacy laws in china
these big tech companies can have access
to data that would be
illegal in like the united states you
know the best organ transplant
breakthroughs
in the past decade have come from china
wow oh but
because people don't believe that the
forced organ harvesting is happening
there even though there is copious
amounts of evidence that this is
happening
for example uh i remember this
specifically the kunming kidney disease
center
had a promise that if the first
transplant didn't work
they would keep doing them until it did
work and wouldn't charge you and if you
know anything about transplant it is
impossible
to have like a bunch of kidneys lined up
yes yeah there was a story that first
you know yeah
there was a story that broke this summer
where a chinese woman who lived in japan
um had to go back to china for this is a
heartwarming experience
for a heart transplant it took them
three hearts
before she got one that she could like
that worked
and like it was like it was it was
actually like
you know portrayed in chinese state-run
media as this great
thing that like she was the the you know
the country cared about her so much the
party cared about her so much that they
brought her from japan
and they gave her hearts until it worked
you know
and they accidentally admitted that they
had you know
this little bank of prisoners or
whatever we you know at least i've
laughed at some pretty dark things but
it's the sheer absurdity
of how awful it is and it's just
keeps happening it's been happening i
mean how the the the the
in the insane stories that we have go
back what to what when when this all
start happening in china
well which specifically are you talking
just like the the communist party
oh the communist party was doing insane
things uh even before it
successfully conquered china we we have
stories going back
you know how many years is it now is it
80 it's that's 100 years
since the party really yeah 100 years of
the most psychotic things you've ever
heard and it's only getting worse it
seems
with new technology being given by the
west
yeah and we sit here today and
you know how long are these concentra uh
concentration camps been going on
at least since what 2017 well if you're
talking specifically about the uyghurs
probably since 2015 they really started
to round people up
falun gong before that falun gong in
1999
yeah and that was like black jails or
just the prison systems
uh military hunters we were supposed to
uh
you know never let something like this
ever happen again
you know the people of the world we've
let it happen twice within the last
20 years right right and and disney's
clapping for it oh yeah and the and how
many users does disney plus have like
100 something million or whatever
and then the head guy is going to become
the ambassador to china yeah i think
he'd be a great investor
but we're watching all of this happen we
know it's happening
and for some reason it's just gonna keep
happening well the media has completely
failed on the story of organ harvesting
uh that you only really started to see
any reporting on
organ harvesting uh in the past year
after
a group called the china tribunal which
was led by a guy named sir jeffrey nice
who oversaw the
war crime trial of slovenian milosevic
uh they spent like a year they spent
like a year looking into it and
like ruled like this is definitely
happening this is not a conspiracy this
isn't something being made up
and there in this tribunal there is an
interesting story
where a former new york times reporter
dd kirsten tatlow
uh was in china she said she overheard
officials talking about or
it was two doctors she was at like
she was doing stories about organ
harvesting but not related to the forced
organ harvesting related to the idea
that china was going to start using
organ donors
and and then she said okay she was at a
dinner with these two chinese doctors
and like they were talking about this
like
the fact that the chinese government had
said they're no longer
going to use prisoner organs and then
one of the doctors said to the others
the other we can't use prisoner organs
and the other doctor said no
and then the other doctor was like what
about prisoners of conscience
and the other doctor was like no can't
use those anymore either
and then she overheard she heard them
say this in front of her and then she
went to her editors and was like at the
new york times i would like to
look into this forced organ harvesting
thing because i think
you know there's i heard overheard this
conversation
there's something weird with the numbers
like i would like to look into the story
and she was
discouraged from looking into the story
she was told
is there really anything new here also
you know the people who
talk about organ harvesting are on the
outer fringes of advocacy
yeah like a nice way of saying that
these are only like crackpot conspiracy
theorists people who believe in this
and so she was about to discouraged from
looking into this
the new york times still has not covered
the tribunal as far as i've seen and
then
um basically she also thinks that
bringing this up uh
was one of the reasons she didn't get a
promotion later because her editors
like were so upset about this that's how
the game has played with these media
companies
don't rock the boat we want to make we
want to make money so it look you know
especially right now in media one of the
one of the stories we covered the other
day is that cnn's president jeff zucker
is
probably going to quit i mean he's
thinking about it you know they say it's
because he's having a
a bit of a fight with his boss but come
on no trump no ratings they found a
really really easy path that was only
somewhat controversial
you're not going to make any of your
advertisers angry you're not going to
make any any foreign countries angry
you're not going to risk your
circulation in certain places if you
just rag on trump 24 7 you'll make money
easiest path to cash no no real
journalism required
and that's what we ended up with so this
is great if they
collapse that means people will only
have tim cast and china and censor
i think that's uh well i think i think
what's going to happen interestingly
these media companies have were on the
verge of death before trump
uh when trump came in it gave them
something to do now i think we're going
to see
some kind of rebalancing between
mainstream narratives
and independent media so what this means
i guess ultimately
is that independent channels will have
much more influence in the news cycle
the new york times has been doing really
really well
cnn and msnbc and the networks are going
to collapse and that means
those airport news channels won't have
that that power so this could be a good
thing so maybe it's not
not over entirely but i do think
seeing the you know i think that the
democrats are gonna take georgia
uh trump's not on the ticket and for the
senate for the senate right
without uh donald trump on the ticket
trump supporters are not going to back
mitch mcconnell and the republicans
the republicans certainly will trump
supporters are telling mitch gtfo
so if the democrats end up taking
everything and we have a president who
is
in my opinion you know compromised by
china but at the very least we'll call
him sympathetic based on the people you
mentioned that he surrounds himself with
i think china's going to get car blocked
they're going to do what they want and
u.s won't stand in their way
if anything u.s is going to help him the
new york times just uh put out a piece
today about how to reset the
relationship with china
yeah and it was full of um advice from
people from goldman sachs and citigroup
huawei and huawei yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time